Avengers 5 banner take to mark boy is
this not a simpler is this not your
natural state it's the unspoken truth of
humanity the sorry my nervous demeanor
comes out in the presence of large
crowds where was I oh right you were
made to be ruled in the end you will
always kneel
nothi men like you there are no other
men like me thank you
clearly your old age is not probably
much wisdom whereas there may be other
Homo sapiens who resemble my biological
features I'm truly a unique individual
not unlike the uniqueness of each
individual yet similarly structured
snowflake loci one old German dude
negative one buzz Anka not many have
successfully snuck up on me but you
figure to come I thought you might I
hope you are not expecting to engage in
coitus I want to know what you've done
to agent Gordon and why is that of
importance to you does he meet your
ideal physical requirements for
reproduction before I worked for shield
I well I made a name for myself I have a
very specific skillset said Liam Neeson
you set a line that was from taken my
plan is to take over this feeble world
by Sunday before Game of Thrones comes
on at 9:00 not a great plan when they
come and they will they'll come for you
I can take it I have an IQ of over 147
we have a Hulk I have the Hulk on DVD
and the other Hulk on blu-ray as well as
a bunch of Hulk comics and oh yeah
Hulk hands by Hasbro let go